we are back with a stunning example of
what a difference a year makes in
combating crime during Obama's last year
in office the killing of police officers
by gunfire hit a five-year high now
under President Trump those killings are
down by a remarkable 34 percent
according to the National Law
Enforcement Officers Memorial Fund one
big difference may be a simple change in
attitude according to a former high
ranking FBI official well look since the
days of his campaign that the president
went out of his way to thank the men and
women in law enforcement for their
sacrifice and say that effectively I
stand with you
that is a hundred and eighty degrees
away from the last few years really
going back to 2009 of the Obama
administration where the presumption was
that the police were racist the police
did something wrong until proven
innocent and and I think that tone maybe
were sensing a or feeling a Trump effect
now he says a Trump effect well there's
more good news the violent crime rate is
down in the nation's 30 largest cities
including the murder rate according to a
study by NYU's Brennan Center for
Justice violent crime down by 1.1
percent even better news the murder rate
in America's biggest 30 cities dropped
by 5.6 percent that includes eight and
eleven point nine percent decline in
Chicago we'll just had a lot of
attention obviously for many years and a
nine point eight percent drop in Detroit
is this encouraging trend here to stay
and does President Trump
deserve the credit let's ask journalist
Heather McDonald the author of last
year's critically acclaimed book the war
on cops how the new attack on law and
order makes everyone less safe also
joining us is Michael Taubman a
Democratic strategist and former senior
aide to Senator Chuck Schumer thank you
both for joining us this evening Heather
let me start with you the the previous
soundbite that we played you know said
that the presumption that the police are
racist is the way maybe a couple years
ago and and whether it was black lives
matter and Barack Obama's presidency
juxtapose that with President Trump I
think we could all would say he has the
presumption that the police are heroes
did that deserve that we deserve they
deserve his backing and our backing how
much does that ethos affect these rates
or could it well there's been a sea
change in both rhetoric and Paula
Pete it's extraordinary because we did
go through eight years where President
Obama took every opportunity to
reinforce the false black lives matter
narrative that we're living through an
epidemic of racially biased police
shootings of black men that resulted in
real demoralization among our police
forces and deep policing officers were
reluctant to get out of their cars and
make that stop at two am questioning
somebody hanging out on a known drug
corner hitching up his waistband as if
he has a gun because they were fearful
the media the mainstream media would
label them as racists today we have a
Justice Department led by attorney
general sessions who is trying to
reverse some of the anti cop policies of
the Obama administration and Trump is
not serving as an echo chamber for black
lives matter movement I hope that what
is going on is that cops are going back
to proactive policing and we can hope
that more black lives will be saved this
year than we're lost in the last two
certainly the trends look like that may
be the case Michael I've never walked
the beat as a cop but I have walked the
beat on patrol in the military and if
you don't believe in your mission or you
don't think your commander has your back
or your your morale your confidence is
low you are far less likely to be
aggressive or take that proactive
measure how much of that morale or
confidence and that the restoration of
it with this president focusing on how
much might that actually matter at the
ground level I think it actually is from
the ground level up and not the top down
I think changes in policy with the
political appointments and even the
occupant of the White House does have
some say on this I agree with that point
but I would disagree on many others I
think it's actually to the credit of
local policing city by city in each of
those cities you discuss those very
startling very encouraging drops in
violent crime it's local policing I
totally agree with you but but yes
morale has a big part of it and I think
that people that whether it's their
their Patrolmen's Benevolent Association
here in New York City or the police
commissioner or a mayor and we see
constant controversy and tension between
the New York City PBA and mayor de
Blasio but I really think it's a credit
to the local policing and I think
attributing it solely to the tough on
crime rhetoric of candidate Trump and
then press
Trump does local police certainly I
don't think you can good point you can't
credit it all to the president but you
almost can imagine what if colin
kaepernick he had taken a knee during
the obama presidency what have you even
been invited to the White House and
lauded as a hero instead he was called
out specifically by President Trump you
know law enforcement officers and police
officers love the fact that he's a blue
lives matter guy not a black lives
matter guy but that does trickle down a
local guy on the beat really does care
whether or not he's going to be seen as
guilty before before the action is even
taken right I think that's an excellent
example I would also just point to some
of the policies and I agree that
policing is fundamentally a local
phenomenon nevertheless there's things
that attorney General Sessions has done
that are also sending a very powerful
message to cops he has tried to free
departments from the unnecessary and
costly consent decrees that the Obama
administration put on he has said to us
prosecutors we want you to go after
violent felons and drug felons without
worry about the pseudo mass
incarceration narrative being used
against you and again these things are
both effective in themselves and they do
send a message to cops of course
policing and and a drop in crime is due
to the local cops on the ground but the
narrative matters and and an echo
chamber in the White House for a false
narrative did a heck of a lot of damage
over the last couple of years to the
law-abiding residents of inner city
neighborhood I stand corrected by the
way calling capping first kneeled when
Barack Obama was president but but the
the effect of course was amplified
during this president none of the shook
loss over that there are very real and
very serious and historically rooted
tensions between law enforcement and
professional policing and communities of
color throughout the country that being
said I think that some credit is also
due to those in the activist community
who realized that their message was
being lost in this awful tragic violence
in which law-enforcement professionals
were losing their lives nobody wants
that that was it was it was a tragedy
every time that had happened that I
think people know without being called
out debt isn't does that happen
naturally or is that that is where I
would say that candidate Trump was
perhaps uniquely
to deliver a message that other
candidates felt constrained and unable
to deliver on that point I would agree
but on the others I think it's a
consequence of of local policing well
we've got to leave it right there a
couple of a couple of very informed
opinions or Heather McDonald Michael
told me thank you thank you appreciate
it